but Colorado moms push to make it easier
for children to run lemonade stands
without breaking the law highlights a
nationwide problem Jennifer Noll says
Denver police shut down her kids stand
earlier this year well last night she
petitioned lawmakers to make it easier
for kids to sell concessions knowles
started an advocacy group called
lemonade stand
mama Mary Pearson shows us her effort to
in her words turn lemons into lemonade
- Jennifer Knowles and her three boys it
was a family enterprise selling lemonade
and giving all the proceeds to help
children in poverty I wanted to teach my
kids two important lessons of
entrepreneurship and charity lifelong
lessons that all children to learn about
but it was in a city park and police
shut them down for lack of permits that
other concessionaires did have they were
just doing their job and I'm doing my
job trying to get the laws changed so
it's a better opportunity for for
everybody involved Ben is 7 the oldest
of the boys did they explain why they
yes I talked about the old pool image
their kid business came with a very
grown-up lesson that Denver requires
three permits to sell food and beverages
on public property regardless of age the
solution is surprisingly simple just
move on to private property says Eric
Escudero of Denver's office for excise
and licenses in most cases kids still
have to worry about setting up a
lemonade stand if they do it in front of
their house the last thing that the city
of Denver wants to do is discourage the
entrepreneurship of kids the fight over
eliminate stands is not isolated to
Denver the freedom center of Missouri
says there are dozens of cases across
the u.s. where local authorities have
restricted kid run concession stands
tastes like justice country time
lemonade even pledged to pay kids
permitting fees or fines if they're
busted for selling lemonade so far they
have had more than 400 registrations and
reimbursed five permit fees and fines
and turned into a movement
the nonprofit lemonade day is lobbying
local health departments to change
regulations and Utah is the only state
to pass a law prohibiting local
authorities from requiring kid
businesses to have permits or licenses
I'm Jennifer Knowles a local Denver mom
and Jennifer Knowles now persuaded the
Denver City Council to work on a similar
law I'm trying to make lemonade since
legal across my community and Oates
appeal across the country so we can all
have a cold glass of homemade lemonade
served with a kid smile for CBS this
morning Barry Petersen Denver Colorado
Thank You lemonade stand mama I like
that what the kids sell the lemonade
please